[Music]
for the moral consciousness itself
however its moral view of the world does
not mean that consciousness develops
there in its own notion and makes this
its object it is not conscious of this
antithesis either as regards the form or
the content it does not relate and
compare the sides of this antithesis
with one another but in its development
rolls onward without being the notion
which holds the moments together for it
knows only the pure essence or the
object so far as it is duty so far as it
is an abstract object of its pure
consciousness as a pure knowing or as
its own self
it thinks therefore only in abstractions
and does not comprehend that is in terms
of the notion consequently the object of
its actual consciousness is not yet
transparent to it it is not the absolute
notion which alone grasps other
necessities a ballute opposite as its
own self it does indeed hold its own
reality like all objective reality to be
uh nacelle but its freedom is the
freedom of pure thought in contrast to
which therefore nature likewise has
arisen as an existence that is equally
free because both are equally present in
it that is the freedom of mere being and
the inclusion of this being within
consciousness it's object becomes one
that has being but at the same time
exists only in thought in the last stage
of the moral view of the world the
content is explicitly such that it's
being is given to it by thought and this
conjunction of being and thought is
pronounced to be in fact what it is
imagining
in paragraph 611 we are now starting to
approach the end of this section there
there's a kind of downward slide taking
place that we're going to see Hegel is
going to be contrasting the notion or
because if the concept with what is here
translated as imagining for Stalin and
we've seen this play itself out many
times already within the phenomenology
whenever there's for Stalin or for SH
that long we can translate it as
representation here it's being
translated as imagination which works
just fine and that is always going to be
lesser than the concept so what does
this mean then for the moral
consciousness or he says the moral view
of the world the more a lot more
Alisha's veldt on showers right how is
that being worked out here there's a
slippage that's now occurred so he says
for this moral consciousness the moral
view of the world does not mean that
consciousness develops there in its own
notion it's not grasping itself
conceptually and he says it doesn't make
it its object what does this mean he
goes on and this is a very important
phrase here it is not conscious of this
antithesis this Gaghan is that's
contradiction and notice what he says
here either as regards the form or as
the content
whywould grasping its form or content be
important in this case well these are
both two aspects of what makes something
what it is and they're different from
each other you know a form is at a
higher level content is more determinate
and he's saying it's not getting any of
these now why would that be the results
of this entire development within this
long section because moral consciousness
turns out to be a bit more complicated
than was originally thought it's going
to get simplified
here but the simplification ends up
being a missing it a loss a inadequacy
so he goes on and he says it does not
relate and compare the sides of this
antithesis with one another but just
rolls forward it jumps right ahead to
having something that it can work with
as an object who says it knows only the
pure assets or the object insofar as it
is duty and Hegel calls this abstract an
abstract object of its pure
consciousness appear knowing or its own
pure self so what it's working with here
is something that is more malleable for
it that is more satisfying for it but
has gotten away from the complex reality
of moral consciousness so he talks about
this as being thinking in terms of
abstraction which means that it's not
going to grasp the notion and here's
something kind of useful for us to keep
in mind when we see the word for Stalin
or for Xiao long and we think in terms
of representation we will often think in
terms of sensuous representations or
schemas like what I put on the
chalkboard as opposed to the conceptual
grasping of it and we lose sight of the
fact that these are abstractions in some
sense the thinking subject being taken
out of it makes everything abstract so
representations may be particular but
they are abstract so he goes on and he
says what have we lost here the object
of its actual consciousness is not yet
transparent to it it's not the absolute
notion which grasps other nests as such
and we've seen other news coming up in
the previous paragraphs
nor does it grasp its absolute opposite
as its own self typical Hegelian
dialectic there so what does it get he
says it does indeed hold its own reality
to be honest ntral but it's freedom as
the freedom of pure thought and contra
to which Nature has arisen as an
existence that's equally free we saw
this entire dialectic play itself out
earlier we've got nature versus duty
happiness versus Duty all of these
things coming together and consciousness
was making sense out of it as moral
consciousness but now it's lost ahold of
that and what does it gain in its place
this thinking of being freedom of mere
being right that's nature and the
inclusion of this being within
consciousness he says its object becomes
one that has being but at the same time
exists only in thought so what kind of
being only exists in thought an
imagination right he says the in the
last stage of the moral view of the
world the content is explicitly such
that as being is given to it by thought
and this conjunction of being in thought
is pronounced to be what it is in fact
imagining forced elam and this is viewed
as a good resolution by some people but
Hegel saying this is inadequate
when we consider the moral view of the
world in such a way that this objective
mode is nothing else than the very
notion of moral self-consciousness which
it makes objective to itself this
awareness of the form of its origin
gives rise to its exposition in another
shape the first stage which forms the
starting point is the actual moral
self-consciousness or the fact that
there is such a moral self-consciousness
for the notion gives it this explicit
character that is that all reality in
general has essential being for it only
so far as it is in conformity with duty
and this essential being it
characterizes as knowledge that is as an
immediate unity with the actual self
hence this unity is itself actual it is
a moral actual consciousness this now
qua consciousness pictures its content
to itself as an object that is as the
final purpose of the world as harmony of
morality and all reality but since it
thinks of this unity as object and is
not the notion which has mastery over
the object of such the unity is a
negative of self consciousness for it or
it falls outside of it as something
beyond its actual existence and yet at
the same time is something that also has
being but a being existing only in
thought
paragraph 612 takes off from the force
tellin the imagining that was taking
place in the previous paragraph this
being existing only in thought having a
place only in thought and is recapping
the movement that has taken place so far
you notice that here Hegel is talking
about a first shape or it's also
translated here rather periphrastic Lee
as stage a Gestalt so he's rehashing
what we've gone through already and in
the paragraphs yet to come he's gonna
flesh this out further so he says when
we consider the moral view of the world
what's involved in the moral view of the
world in such a way that this objective
this Gagan stanley commode is nothing
else than the very notion of moral
self-consciousness which it makes
objective to itself that is it makes
moral self-consciousness something that
is consciousness of itself as something
that is doing something in reality in
the world either acting or being within
the world when it makes it objective in
this way he says the this awareness of
the form of its origin gives rise to its
exposition it's Darsh telling it's being
set forth being being put out there in
another shape in another stage so he
says the first stage which forms the
starting point is actual vehicle iike
moral self-consciousness which we've
talked about quite a bit or this is very
important here because Hegel is going to
turn this into the mirror image of
another proposition there is moral
self-consciousness something that we can
assert to ourselves now when we do so of
course we aren't just sitting back and
saying oh that's so interesting there's
moral self-consciousness I wonder what
it will do this is practical we say oh
there's moral self-consciousness wait a
second that's me I'm
moral self-consciousness and so should
you be so we're aware of it through
ourselves and as something that's that's
there he goes down and he says the
notion gives this explicit character
that all reality in general has a
central being for it only insofar as
it's in conformity with gnudi now does
that mean that only Duty exists no only
has essential being in so far it's only
you might say fully being in so far as
it's in accordance with duty which means
that we ourselves are transforming being
both the being outside of ourselves and
the being that is ourselves precisely by
imposing this notion of Duty or flicked
right obligation on to it and then
acting accordingly choosing accordingly
aligning ourselves with that Duty making
the duty be real via clique so he says
this essential being it characterizes as
knowledge visum as an immediate unity
with the actual self and we know
ourselves not just in terms of sort of
theoretical knowledge but practically in
relation to duty this is nothing new
we've already talked about this quite
quite great length in the previous
paragraphs so he says hence this unity
is itself actual it is that is it as
being a moral actual consciousness now
how do we get from there to somewhere
else he says this now as consciousness
pictures or imagines its content to
itself as an object it makes it gagging
steadily it makes it something it can
manage and here we saw that there there
were several different antitheses that
were being talked about one of them has
to do with the final purpose of the
world the ends Veck the goal that is the
goal of goals right
what is that a harmony between morality
and reality via Kate
actuality you could say as well if you
want to so how do these get harmonized
you know we saw that there isn't really
any genuine existence of this this
harmony but it is something that we have
to think we have to postulate it that
was what Kant said and Hegel has been
working through that entire dynamic so
he says Sensa thinks of this unity as an
object and is not the notion now notice
we started with being the notion and now
we've got to slip it we've lost the
notion it's not the notion which has
mastery over the object as such the
unity is a negative of
self-consciousness for it this unity
falls outside Hegel says of
self-consciousness and what does that
mean says it be it's beyond its actual
existence and we know this do we ever
see a harmony of morality and reality or
actuality whether out in the world or
even within ourselves no we're a mess
the world's a mess and yet we do have
these moral norms there that are saying
you should do this don't do that how do
we actually work through this so he says
it's beyond our it's actual existence
and yet at the same time something that
also has being how does it have being
being existing only in thought imagining
right this is going to lead us to the
second shape or stage which Hegel
doesn't identify at this point but which
comes up in the next paragraph
this self-consciousness which quoi
self-consciousness is other than the
object is thus left with the lack of
harmony between the consciousness of
duty and reality and that to its own
reality accordingly the proposition now
runs as follows there is no moral
perfect actual self-consciousness and
since the moral sphere is at all only
insofar as it is perfect for duty as a
pure unadulterated intrinsic being or in
itself and morality consists only in
conformity to this pure in itself the
second proposition simply runs there is
no moral existence in reality
now in paragraph 613 Hegel is spelling
out for us what the consequences are of
this lack of harmony this nicht harmonii
this loss this discordance that is going
on and the Miller translation can be a
little bit misleading on this point
because Hegel does not actually talk of
a consciousness of duty and a
consciousness of reality at the lexical
level although there's no reason why you
couldn't read that in but but I wanted
to just call that to mind so this he
says this self-consciousness which qua
self-consciousness is other than the
object is left with the lack of harmony
a lack of harmony between consciousness
of Duty and reality in flicked below
sign and veer clear-cut right so these
things are clashing with each other and
then he says and also its own reality so
there's a reality of the world of the
all-encompassing reality and then
there's its own reality and it realizes
that none of these are actually mapping
onto each other none of them are jiving
with each other and why does this
constitute a real problem here well he
says accordingly the proposition now
runs as follows there's no moral perfect
actual self consciousness so there's no
self consciousness that is completely
moral completely actual completely
perfect brought to its fulfillment and
you might say well that's that's fine
you know everybody fails you know
nothing is is entirely what it is and
yet when it comes to duty or morality
there's a demand that goes beyond the
scope of reality itself which is kind of
a mishmash in that way and imposes a
higher standard and so what do we get in
this ongoing development of the moral
consciousness something very very
paradoxical that reflects this lack of
harmony he says since the moral sphere
is at all only insofar as it's perfect
because duty is the pure unadulterated
intrinsic being or in itself and
morality consists only in conformity to
this pure in itself the second
proposition is reformulated and it says
again the text a little bit misleading
there is no moral existence in reality
the German is actually a little bit more
blunt there is no moral reality there is
no moral actuality there is no moral
moral Isha
vir CLE kite so we're presented here
with a paradox because we do have moral
consciousness and yet it doesn't seem
like we have morality or moral beings
anywhere that we can look and find them
since however in the third place it is a
single self it is in itself or
implicitly the unity of duty and reality
this unity therefore becomes an object
for it as perfect morality but as a
beyond of its reality yet a beyond that
ought to be actual
paragraph 614 the penultimate paragraph
of this small section on the moral
self-consciousness and moral view of the
world is very very short but it's quite
important to see what is going on here
in a way it's it's brevity as opposed to
many other paragraphs allows what is
going on to be seen and it's its purity
so he talks about the third-place right
Britain's because in the third place it
is a single that is ein self right
Ines ELPS he says it is in itself this
is the consciousness or implicitly a
unity of duty and reality duty and
vehicle attack shew ality something that
that has genuine being here in the world
and he says this unity becomes an object
once again it makes it into an object
for consciousness but it's not an object
that it can find out here in the world
instead it's something that it is
projecting and saying I should be able
to find this somewhere I just haven't
found it yet and it's something that I
need to think as quite possible and what
is this he says it becomes an object for
it as perfect morality and we should
pause here on this perfect word for a
moment that played a role on the
previous paragraph right perfect is full
ended them this is like perfect when
you're reading Greek philosophy it's not
perfect in the sense of just meeting
some sort of standard that's been placed
out there totally without flaws it's got
a conception involved here of being
brought to its fruition being fulfilled
that the being at the end of its process
of development so why is there no
harmony of morality and and Happiness
morality and nature the pure practical
will and the screwed-up wills that we
have because we're not at the end of the
process yet as we ought to be this is a
sort of ameliorative can
option right and so what we have is
something that's ideal as opposed to
something that is actual and what is
this perfect morality you know making it
into an object he brings up this this
idea of a beyond he tells us that this
is a beyond the yang Zeitz on the other
side of its reality and it's reality is
the reality of the moral consciousness
this is something that is beyond its
actual experience and even its way of
thinking of how this is going to take
place but notice the last thing he says
this is a beyond that ought to be actual
so the ideal in this case should be made
actual it's not just an idea where
you're like well that doesn't exist so
screw it
nobody should ever be moral no the the
fact that it is out there but not yet
actual means that we should make it
actual so we should make it real we
should make it vir Lucas
in this goal of the synthetic unity of
the first two propositions the
self-conscious reality that is actual
self-consciousness as well as duty is
posited as only a superseded moment for
neither of these two is single and
separate on the contrary each of them
whose essential determination lies and
their being free from one another is
thus in the unity no longer free from
the other and each therefore is
superseded hence as regards content they
become as such objects each of which
counts as object for the other and as
regards form in such a way that this
interchange is at the same time only
imagined that is occurs only in thought
or again the actually non moral sphere
because it is equally pure thought and
is raised above its actual existence is
yet in imagination moral and it's taken
to be completely valid in this way the
first proposition that there is a moral
self-consciousness is reinstated but is
bound up with the second that there is
none that is that there is one but only
in imagination or in other words it is
true that there is none yet all the same
it is allowed by another consciousness
to pass for one
paragraph 615 brings this section to a
resounding close and it's also
remarkable for a reason that I think
those who actually read the
phenomenology or follow along with this
commentary won't be completely surprised
by and those who get their ideas about
Hegel from secondary glosses would in
fact be very surprised by which is that
this is one of the rare occasions where
we see something like the famous
but misleading thesis antithesis
synthesis exposition of hegelian
dialectic here in the phenomenology as a
matter of fact Hegel will go so far as
to use the term synthetic unity and he
uses that you know synthesis there he
doesn't call it a synthesis but he does
call it a synthetic unity and there
isn't a thesis antithesis you know but
there has been a movement there right so
it's kind of cool to see that happen
every once in a while and this is
something where he talks about things
being superseded or alcohol burn so we
have this process of oh hey bong the
movement to another stage happening here
right before we begin the next section
so he begins by saying that there's a
goal at zeal right of this synthetic
unity of the first two propositions
where is that goal well it's in the last
paragraph that we just talked about the
third right he says the self conscious
reality that is actual self
consciousness as well as Duty is posited
as only a superseded in alcohol bonus
moment so now things have been brought
together in a conceptual unity it says
neither of these is single and separate
each of them whose essential
determination lies in their being free
from one another being sort of standing
on their own is the sin the unity no
longer free and each as their forged
uses this term superseded of colbus
right so what does that mean he says as
regards content they become as
objects each of which counts as an
object for another so each of these
propositions the first proposition there
is moral self-consciousness the second
proposition there is no moral actuality
about as far apart from each other as we
could get they are brought together in a
kind of synthesis and what is it we saw
that in the previous paragraph morality
should be actual that is the thing that
unites them together and in this both of
them become objects for each other you
could imagine them speaking to each
other you know the one says there's
moral self-consciousness and the other
one says that's all bs there's no
morality man it's all just whatever is
and then the other side thing there's no
moral actuality and then the other one
asserts yet we even talking about
morality and saying that it's not there
there's something going on there's
something you're not taking account of
and so they can become objects for each
other within that unity and that's what
allows them to be made sense of I see
this all the time in my ethics classes
when I begin teaching and I talk about
moral norms and there are some people
who get so boggled by the fact well
there's really two different facts here
that illustrate this very well one is
you'll say here's a moral norm that you
should be observing and somebody will
come along and say yeah but people don't
observe that and you'll say that doesn't
actually make it not a norm and they'll
say well but I mean if gravity applies
everywhere that's that's a norm that's a
law of nature and you're like buddy
physics ethics not the same thing it
doesn't work the same way these are two
different ranges of reality sure you can
say that you shouldn't lie and there's
all sorts of people out there breaking
that rule all the time or you should you
know you should fulfill your promises or
you should be benevolent and people
break these rules all the time that does
not mean that they are not rules
that's the emphasizing this side too
much
and there's the other flipside where
people are like why are we even teaching
this this is all just common sense
everybody knows that you shouldn't lie
and you're like well not everybody does
and of the people who do many of them
find themselves tempted and they they
have this sort of incomprehension that
anybody could ever do anything wrong and
when you have that that's a sign of you
know if not a mental disorder at least
in a extremely inflexible consciousness
that cannot grasp human realities out
there in the world now both of those are
one-sided positions and are brought
together in a higher position that says
yeah yeah yeah we get it
morality isn't perfected at this point
and you might even say it doesn't even
exist but yet it should exist and and
that puts everything into perspective
here so he says here we go as regards
content they become objects each of
which counts as an object for the other
as regards form in such a way that this
interchanges is very important is at the
same time only imagine that is only
occurs in thought and then he says
here's another way to explain it the
actually non moral sphere because it's
equally pure thought is raised above its
actual existence is yet against again he
see this term in imagination moral and
it's taken to be completely valid so he
says in this way the first proposition
is reinstated but is bound up with the
second he says there is moral
consciousness but only in imagination in
other words it is true that there is
none yet all the same it is allowed by
another consciousness to pass for one so
this way in which we parse out morality
should be actual is replace it in the
realm of imagination or if you like the
four Stalin could also mean something
that we're sort of projecting out there
ahead of ourselves
right and this is not yet a full
resolution of this this problem and
relying on imagination like that is
going to introduce some new problems of
its own but that is where Hegel takes
this
you